in today's eight on your side how many
of you are still waiting to get your
hands on a playstation 5 or xbox's
newest release some people in here
shaking their heads
maybe you missed the holiday window like
i did very difficult
still months out after the launch to get
a hold of either
if you're serious about it you either
have to sit in front of a computer all
day and hit refresh or subscribe to
twitter feeds or watch channels on
youtube who's got that kind of time
right
well pop cart is an online tool created
to help when you shop compare prices
and they've come up with an alert that
you can download
the game consoles the playstation 5 and
xbox releases from sony and microsoft
were
in incredibly short supply we actually
built a whole feature
called pop cart genius alerts just to
help you track them back in stock and
that's
still one of our most popular features
you set an alert for a playstation
and whenever whenever there's a drop on
best buy or target
we let you know omri traub is the
founder of popcart he says including
best buy and target it'll also let you
know the availability on the biggest
shopping sites like amazon as well with
a ding on your browser or
an email